have a look at it we need y is greater
than the square root Jacob
Oh 25 minus x squared now what's our
normal approach for doing it they're
really kind of two steps have been using
so far firstly we think about the
boundary right where is the boundary so
you have a look at this guy
do you recognize what this shape is
going to be if I change the inequality
for equal sign is it a semicircle right
what kind of semicircle if it's a
top-class right because by definition we
define the square root of bah-bah-bah
you will not in any way to be positive
if I wanted to embark on for what I do
I type of - titled in right and then you
get communities okay so now that I've
got this part and it's dr. dividend so
I'm going to do that okay now it passes
through the coordinate axes it's an
important point
what are a 5 and 5s
so far so good
now let's think about testing give me a
point to test whatever I possibly can
I will test the origin if it's not a
while the boundary or if it doesn't
represent some discontinuity such as
over here okay so if I just here here
rather I'll get to your point in a
minute
might I see right here dollars the
origin satisfied ecology on it does not
because viewer is not grazing fine right
okay so I know that this area down here
is not going to be in here right now my
question to you is what is the rest of
the air what is the other side that I
get is it going to look like this
because it'll it weird right like unlike
all these guys right this does not
actually divide up the quarter axes into
anything right because it's it's open is
it inside or outside like the inside is
the outside right you don't pass through
any boundaries to do that okay so what
is the asset yeah if you think back to
this rule of thumb that I've been trying
to communicate across to you well why is
the subject a great event in the case
above and unless they're indicated below
right what you're going to find is not
be a little bit weird you can get these
spots up here these are all fine but it
doesn't just go to forever for example
this point over here isn't going to work
nor is this one why not
think carefully my clue is to have a
look at this right inside it's like yeah
how about square you can't have the x
squared B greater than than 25 this is
why this idea comes after all that stuff
we looked at with range and domain
remember that look nothing has been said
but there is a domain restriction that
has been implied just by saying the
square root of 25 minus x squared okay
one needs the range of future you can
see if I brought it right I've got B
greater than negative 5 but it's got to
be less than positive 5 okay
so therefore implies here are some extra
boundaries just like this what are the
equations I misspeak adeje what in
equations of these numbers x equals
negative 5 and so I'm deliberately
showing you this guy and this guy to
help you remember all the stuff you've
done on domain restriction
it's important X equal zero was not told
to you as something that would be a
boundary but here's just like X equal
negative by this bottom okay life is
production because we have this correct
region in here it really gives
everywhere including these up to their
edges right something I hadn't really
been talking about because it hasn't
been relevant yet there are not just
boundary lines there also if you will
carefully some boundary points to note
that see these guys come together and
they meet have what coordinates negative
5 0 there's a boundary point man and 5 0
that is also a boundary point are they
going to be included in my inequality or
not
they're not going to include I so I'm
going to leave them hollowed just like I
will under number one okay
last thing just to on fish this off what
if I had said this
what would it look like now so if the
site is I think you sort of clued in
arcade is boundary here that can be
filled in like that
okay what about a value like this this
boundary point where the work look is 0
greater than or equal to the square root
of 25 minus 25 and the answer is yes it
is it's exactly equal so this would be
included and then this would be included
and if you extend that logic more
carefully
therefore all of this will also include
right and all of this will also be
included because the right-hand side
will be 0 and they'll then take time and
just increase and increase strength so
exist